did you know that two out of every three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern borders by the time they're 35
yeah i did for me it was more like 25. i
wish keeps have been around when i was
younger because advancements in science
meant that there are now treatments that
can come at the symptoms of hair loss so
you can keep the hair that you have look
it's too late for me my hair is not
coming back but you don't have to be
like me you can stop your hair loss
early thanks to keeps keeps offers
generic versions of the only two fda
approved drugs for treating hair loss so
you might have tried them before but
never at a price this low that's right
if you were thinking uh some sort of
medicine simon it's gonna be expensive
well don't worry keep starts at just ten
dollars a month how does it work well
for one thing there's no need to visit a
doctor's office just schedule a quick
online consult a little bit later
discreet package gonna arrive at your
door so if you're noticing that you're
losing your hair it's not a problem
that's gonna fix itself guys do
something about it for a limited time go
to keeps.com forward slash biographics
or you just click the link in the
description below to save 50 of your
first order and now today's video
legend has it that on the 20th of june
1941 a team of soviet archaeologists
opened the tomb of a mighty central
asian ruler whose ruthlessness and skill
in battle was second only to genghis
khan his tomb bore the inscription when
i rise from the dead the world shall
tremble when the archaeologists located
the coffin they read an even more
ominous threat whoever opens my tomb
shall unleash an invader more terrible
than i two days later hitler launched
operation barbarossa against the ussr
the largest land invasion in history the
legend goes that when the fearsome
warlord was again sealed in his tomb the
soviets won at stalingrad this
archaeological expedition actually took
place but i wouldn't bet on the accuracy
of any other details but this story
captures the fierce reputation of
today's protagonist amir tamur the lane
also known as tamerlane abandoned a
mercenary of mongol origin he rose
through the ranks becoming the most
powerful ruler in the 14th century
islamic world eventually he conquered an
empire stretching from delhi to the
mediterranean in the words of historian
beatrice forbes manns timur could boast
a stature bigger than life and a
charisma bordering on the supernatural
before we get into the birth and rise of
today's protagonist let me give you a
little bit of context after the death of
genghis khan the mongol empire was split
between four of his descendants his
second son chagatai inherited a vast
territory in central asia which became
known as the chaga hired carnate this
policy included most of modern day's
bekistad kazakhstan parts of mongolia
and china's jinyang province the
carnate's economy was based on thematic
herding and was less outwardly
aggressive than its northern neighbor
the golden horde this wasn't out of the
kindness of their hearts but because of
constant internal strife and division
eventually the chag had eyed carnate
fragmented into several entities the
largest being the powerful moghelestan
in the east and the less formidable
trans-soxiana in the west in this
divided land a boy was born in 1336 a.d
his birthplace was kesh modern-day
sharbs arbs in uzbekistan his father was
called tarakai a minor nobleman of the
nomadic barlis tribe these were a sunni
muslim turkisized mongol group once
allied to chagatai a birth he was called
timur meaning iron a name which carried
an omen of strength tenacity and
conquest timur and family never had a
place to call home following nomadic
habits they roamed the steps south of
the capital samacans looking for the
best pastures for their livestock the
young timur soon grew tired of looking
after grazing animals his parents were
not clan leaders but the barlow society
allowed upward mobility for tough
youngsters who were handy with a
composite bow especially if shot from
horseback timur displayed a clear talent
for violence in action a talent which he
put to fruition by stealing horses and
sheep from neighboring clans soon he
added banditry to cattle rustling on his
cv and built a following of like-minded
young warriors at the age of 21 in 1357
timur trained his gang into a mercenary
outfit and entered the service of tug
luck tamar the khan of nearby kashgar
shortly afterwards the ruler of
transaxiana amir khasgan died tuglaque
took the opportunity to invade and in
1361 he conquered samakand the young
timur must have played an important role
in the conquest as he was appointed
chief advisor to turlock's son elias
koha from shepard to bandit to minister
aged only 25. not bad but also not
enough timur was not happy to play
second fiddler to elias koya so he
forged an alliance with the ruler of
balker modern-day afghanistan the emir
or prince hussein the friendship was
consolidated when timur married
hussein's sister the two bros kicked off
a rebellion against two gluck and ilyas
which did not go as planned the two fled
to the region of kharasan southwestern
afghanistan where timur resumed his
mercenary activities in 1363 during a
skirmish with enemy horsemen an arrow
pierced his right hand and knocked him
off his horse as a result he lost his
little and ring fingers and suffered a
permanent injury to his right leg from
then on he developed a lifelong limp he
also acquired the nickname that would
make him immortal timur ilenko timur the
lame better known in the west as
tamerlane
[Music]
at this stage one may define timur as an
exiled upstart with a prominent physical
disability this may have been a clear
disadvantage especially in territories
spawned from the mongol empire which
valued physical prowess and nobility of
blood only descendants from genghis and
their relatives could aspire to the
title of khan but tamar's ambitions knew
no boundaries in 1364 he spotted an
opportunity to continue his climb tugle
could died and it was time to settle
scores with his son ilyas timur and amir
hasan attacked transoxiana conquering
the entire region by 1366. as it
happened before timur was the power in
the shadows while hussein had assumed
titular power as khan establishing a new
capital in balka but the relationship
between the two brothers-in-law started
to sour the khan had grown arrogant
imposing a despotic rule and amassing
the wealth of his subjects according to
some sources he may have even kidnapped
one of timo's sisters to join his harem
as a big no-no of course if you fancy
your best friend's sister it's probably
better to marry her but more
realistically the last draw was when
hussein refused to pay his soldiers
wages in the spring of 1370 tamu started
to plot building alliances with other
military leaders soon he commanded a
formidable army and went on the attack
hussein's forces were beaten time and
again until timur besieged baloch
hussein's loyalists fought desperately
trying two sorties which inflicted heavy
casualties on their enemies but timur
pressed on and a defeated hussein sought
refuge in the mosque of balak offering
all of his riches in exchange for his
life according to contemporary sources
tamur shed some tears at the sight of
his old friend begging for mercy but his
allies bathed for revenge and killed the
khan in cold blood it seems then that
timur's tears dried up very quickly as
he collected an imposing war booty and
married four of hussein's widows one of
them was saray
descendant of genghis khan with this new
found legitimacy tamar restored the
capital and samacand and declared
himself sovereign of the chaghadai
incarnate restorer of the mongol empire
still he styled himself as amir rather
than khan honoring the central asian
traditions but titles meant little to
the pragmatic leader he knew that true
power rested on the saddles and bows of
his unstoppable army and he was ready to
build an empire
for the following 10 years timur fought
endless campaigns conquering areas
corresponding to today's southern
kazakhstan western uzbekistan and the
xinjiang province in china even joined
the golden horde in their fight against
the russians occupied moscow and then he
took on the lithuanians at poltava
ukraine many of these campaigns may have
been dictated by the opportunity to
pillage some sizeable loot but timur was
a capable long-term strategist his end
goal was to consolidate power along the
silk road the wealthiest commercial
route linking europe to the far east by
controlling it he would ensure a
consistent income to fund his
expeditions he appeared to achieve
victory without much effort but of
course the military prowess of his
armies did not happen by chance timur's
horses were a composite bunch with
soldiers joining from every corner of
central and east asia but the corps the
elite came from the steps of transoxyana
these men made up an army some 140 000
strong disciplined and staunchly loyal
timur's almost supernatural charisma
ensured they would follow him everywhere
they fought mainly on horseback and
their weapon of choice was the composite
bow which they mastered from an early
age by their early teens each nomadic
horseman was able to shoot an arrow
every five seconds hitting targets at 60
meters distant these highly mobile units
were complemented by well-trained
infantry specialized in siege warfare
when meeting an enemy in a pitched
battle timur eschewed the traditional
formation which included a center wings
and a reserve instead he split his army
into seven divisions three at the front
three in support and a reserve to the
rear this allowed him to throw in fresh
horses and riders when needed wearing
out the enemy defensive lines
furthermore amir realized the
limitations of his army he knew they
were good at conquering and less so at
holding territories therefore he
concentrated occupation forces in rich
agricultural lands and was happy to let
go of the less profitable steps one such
land full of riches was persia which the
conqueror targeted in 1383. the ruling
ilknid dynasty was extinct and too many
competitors vied to fill the power
vacuum taking advantage of this civil
stripe tamur invaded from the north
capturing herat its inhabitants suffered
horrific treatment which was to serve as
an example for other cities tibor's army
plundered all treasurers leveled ancient
landmarks and slaughtered many of the
defenders rumors of such ruthlessness
spread across the country and several
cities like tehran surrendered without a
fight others like ishvahan fought back
only to regret it later timur ordered a
massacre of ishifan citizens and their
skulls were piled up in morbid towers
several meters high by 1385 all of
eastern persia had fallen the land was
depleted of its riches as well as of its
most talented inhabitants the emir
deported artists architects
intellectuals and artisans to samacans
where they would contribute to the
building of an imperial capital in
tamir's vision the city was to be the
beating heart of the islamic world as
well as the cultural hub of central asia
samakand was to become a tangible
testament to timur's ambition to be
recognized both as the defender of islam
and the restorer of genghis khan's
greatness and the track record of the
lame prince was indeed worthy of his
role model between 1386 and 1394 he was
unstoppable southern iran iraq
mesopotamia and the caucasus all bent
the knee timmer's campaign to control
azerbaijan was conducted alongside
takatamesh khan of the golden horde the
two allies though soon dissented over
who should control the silk road as we
know by now timur was not above turning
against old friends and a new war was on
initially dr thomas had the upper hand
invading trans-oxiana and even besieging
samacand however he was repulsed and
timur chased him back into the russian
steps in 1391 the golden horde was
defeated on the konderche river but they
returned with vengeance four years later
the two armies clashed again in april of
1395 over the terrick river northern
caucasus this time many of tokitamish's
generals defected to the other side and
timur's victory was decisive during this
campaign the unstoppable conqueror
raised the ground the cities of sarai
azov and astrakhan as his attention was
diverted persia revolted against the
emir but the revenge was swift and
utterly brutal more towers of skulls
obscured the sun
[Music]
in september of 1398 timur set his
sights on india in his view the sultan
of delhi mahmoud tuglach was too
tolerant of his hindu subjects he
amassed an army of 90 000 men and
crossed the indus river attacking delhi
on december 17th mack would put up a
strong defense by deploying dozens of
war elephants covered in chain mail and
topped by wooden towers but timur had a
plan he had the battlefield covered with
spiked iron cow troops which wounded and
diverted the attacking beasts then he
unleashed a charge of riderless camels
each carrying a load of blazing hay the
terrified elephants stampeded their own
troops sowing confusion and panic the
wondrous city of delhi soon became
another wasteland of ruins the following
year timur looked to the west to settle
accounts with the ottoman empire and the
mamluk sultanate of egypt guilty of
having seized mongol lands in anatolia
modern-day turkey the confrontation
began with some serious trash talk
tomorrow to the ultimate sultan baazeed
thy obedience to the qur'an in waging
war against the infidels is the sole
consideration that prevents us from
destroying thy country bezid replied
what are the arrows of the flying tartar
against the scimitars and battle axes of
my firm and invincible janissaries well
i guess we'll see won't we the timmerid
steamroller galloped westward storming
aleppo damascus and baghdad in 1401 20
000 of its citizens were slaughtered
after setting camp for the winter timur
reached anatolia in the early summer of
1402. he first laid siege the town of
sivis promising not to shed a drop of
blood if the inhabitants surrendered and
they did three thousand of them then
were buried alive so technically demur
kept his promise the next challenge was
buyers its main army of 85 000 men the
two forces squared off at ankara on the
28th of july timur had managed to turn
many ottoman vassals to his side
outnumbering his foe almost two to one
but baazid knew how to fight a defensive
battle he deployed his infantry along a
stream on hilly terrain thus protected
the infantry could raise a shield wall
shielding the cavalry units from temur's
attacks seeing the futility of the
initial charges tamur decided to wear
out the opponents with a stratagem he
had a creek diverted denying ottoman
horses and their riders from access to
water the demoralized horsemen were
ultimately scattered by a charge of war
elephants which tamora had imported from
delhi the elite janissaries now without
mounted support were easy pickings for
tomorrow's heavy cavalry attacking their
flanks but bayazid inspired his
surrounded men to fight on until
nightfall he then attempted to break out
at the encirclement but was captured by
his enemy the sultan was brought back to
samacant where he suffered a humiliating
captivity at the hands of timur who
allegedly used him as a footstool
the ottomans had thus lost not only
their leader but 40 000 of their finest
soldiers the power vacuum in the ottoman
empire resulted in a civil war to the
delight of western european powers
always weary of the ottoman thread the
kings of england france and castile sent
messages to timur congratulating him on
his victory the castilians even sent an
ambassador to samacand roy gonzalez de
clavio claudio gave a vivid account of
tamur's court and exotic grandiosity he
was especially impressed by the amir's
15 palaces many of which could be
disassembled and moved when necessary he
also described how the supposed defender
of the islamic faith was a heavy drinker
who organized lavish feasts every night
when one guest showed up late to one of
his parties punished him by piercing his
nose like a pig after clavio departed in
november 1404 the ageing tomorrow
prepared for what would be his last
expedition this time on the receiving
end would be ming china the mir had had
a bone to pick with the ming since 1395
when their emperor had sent a message
describing himself as lord of the realms
of the face of the earth and treating
timur as a subordinate he retaliated by
detaining the emperor's envoys when more
messengers came looking for them he also
had them put in jail timur's plan was to
get rid of the arrogant emperor and
replace him with the wan dynasty
descendants of kublai khan the usual
careful planner this time committed a
huge mistake good sense would dictate
initiating military campaigns in the
spring to take advantage of the good
weather and plentiful pastures for the
war horses but timur set off in december
1404 at the head of 200 000 troops his
astrologers had seen good omens in the
stars but
the weather begged to disagree frosty
climber made the trek increasingly
difficult for the army whilst crossing
the seer daya river uzbekistan the once
undefeated leader fell ill possibly as a
consequence of the cold the scourge of
central asia probably had wished for a
glorious death in battle but in february
of 1405 age 69 timur died of natural
causes during his decades of military
successes the prince had failed to
create a functioning government
structure power was almost always
centered around him with no trusted
lieutenant to take his place and inspire
the troops the expedition melted away
the two hundred thousand soldiers
marched back to samakant timur's body
embalmed in oils and laid an ivory
coffin was buried in a splendid
mausoleum
six centuries later the legacy of timur
ylang is controversial to say the least
driven by ambition and skill a disabled
cattle rustler and mercenary had
defeated some of the most powerful
nations in asia in the middle east
assembling a large empire his actions in
anatolia weakened the ottomans long
enough for the byzantine empire to
survive 50 more years and his defeat of
the golden horde allowed for the
expansion of russia lithuania and poland
but while in power he focused mainly on
destruction and conquest some estimates
place his death toll at 17 million about
five percent of the global population at
the time his inattention to political
matters eventually left his empire at
the mercy of foreign invaders as his
line of succession was not clear his
last surviving son and his grandsons
fought each other for dominance losing
the western half of the empire
nonetheless his timaru dynasty survived
for yet another century while samacand
flourished as a center for the arts
literature and science a later
descendant babur took control of kabul
and later delhi founding mughal dynasty
and i'll leave the last word to you
wisdom a great ruler whose actions and
influence had a huge impact on the
geopolitics of eurasia or maybe you
agree with military historian david
nicole who argued timur might have been
a great soldier but in purely historical
terms he could be seen as the greatest
bandit of all times so i really hope you
found this video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below don't forget to subscribe and
thank you for watching
[Music]